phase four hasn't even started releasing
movies yet and we're already getting so
much potential news about Marbella phase
five today's video the Marvel phase five
midnight sons Ghost Rider Elsa
bloodstone blade Doctor Strange and
maybe Morbius too perhaps
hey guys I wanted to mention real fast
that if you haven't done so already make
sure to download and follow us on the
freaking Stardust app we are doing 30
second reviews for films TV shows and
trailers we post like at least seven
times a week maybe that equates to daily
I don't know but it's a lot of fun to
all free to use you can post your own
stuff to tag us follow us first so they
know we sent you you're so good how's it
going everybody it's Warren welcome back
to my channel to cosmic wonder where we
talk about everything relating to Marvel
and of course the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and today we have some phase 5
news specifically revolving around blade
and Moon Knight a new character is going
to be coming to the MCU that could
connect the two and depending on what
Marvel and Sony have worked out with
each other for the spider-man universe
that they share with each other we could
even see this character pop up in a
Morbius venom or spider-man film we
could even have a whole monster universe
coming to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
there's like Morbius blade Sam man
where's Dracula Moon Knight and many
other awesome ones so we'll break down
this new rankeillor coming to phase 5
and talk about what it means but first
congratulations to youtube user rocket
for at for being last week's winner of
the ironman Funko pop giveaway this bill
anyway a Captain America Funko pop from
Avengers in game same rules all you have
to do subscribe like the video leave a
comment about the video down below so
today's report comes from Casey walls
from the website the geeks worldwide and
him and decide their previous people not
too long ago have said that they have
seen Elsa bloodstone name included with
those of bleh
and Moon Knight now if you are unaware
of who Elsa bloodstone is she is the
daughter of Alyssa's bloodstone and
she's an expert Monster Hunter she has
many different powers including
superhuman strength speed stamina
agility she also has the ability to heal
her size she's an expert marksman and
she has the use of mystic powers now
what makes this very interesting about
her joining the MCU is the report that
we are getting a ghostwriter in the MCU
as well and the reason this is
interesting is because it looks like
Marvel could be planning to introduce
the midnight sons this was a group put
together in the comics by ghost writer
and dr. strange that we want to fight
different kinds of threats more mystic
demonic monster type of threats and it's
decide to do this group it seems like we
already know who they're going to put in
the group Doctor Strange of course moon
knight blade Morbius and now of course
Elsa bloodstone now this could be a
pretty incredible group of people in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and we do know
based off of everything that we've heard
so far that Marvel is going to explore
the more mystic side of the universe and
this is all going to start with Wanda
vision we've seen the leaked photos of
the Salem witch trials implying that the
more mystic side is going to be in that
show and of course we know that this is
going to tie into Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness in which he
himself is the master of the mystic arts
we already have Morbius coming out and
we've already seen that it is tied to
the MCU in some way or form and then of
course we have blade and Moon Knight
both have officially been announced by
Marvel Studios and now with the report
that Elsa bloodstone has been attached
to blade and Moon Knight it appears that
the plan for Marvel eventually would be
to unite all of these characters and
form the sons of midnight we know that
Doctor Strange is going to have a lot on
his plate during multiverse of madness
and it might be safe to assume that he
won't be able to contain everything
that's going to happen and perhaps
there's a demon of some sort maybe even
mephesto that gets out that he can't
contain or even multiple demons that
come from other realities and go into
the main reality
what would he do call upon the sons of
midnight and it really would be a
perfect opportunity to connect all of
those characters together blade Morbius
Moon Knight
elsa bloodstone and the one and only
ghostwriter it seems like this is the
path that Marvel's going down and it not
to mention once upon a time ABC almost
did a series about Elsa bloodstone with
Marvel seems like they've had plans for
her for a while and now she's going to
be entering the MCU Sons of midnight
possibly coming to the MCU be sure to
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on everything we're lating to
the MCU the live updates you can follow
me on Twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching will flow
that's exciting
a bunch of men fighting monsters and one
woman and why is Marvel woke there's no
more than one no you can't have two
women or else it's gonna be too much I
mean the idea of getting like Elsa
bloodstone and the Sons of midnight that
does sound awesome
honestly like incredible the context of
that is undeniably something I'm really
gravitated to some of that supernatural
demonic aesthetic horror I just really
really think like and this is my
skepticism with it I love Marvel
I love the MCU I really do I think is
this an absolutely incredible
but when you're doing this type of
storytelling I guess it doesn't need to
be rated R but it should at least push
boundaries it should at least go the
extra mile to feel somewhat scary you
know at least across that aesthetic
threshold yeah and not just like geez
Elyse Carey like I Frankenstein but like
a pg-13 Sam Raimi s kind of scary like
it dragged me to hell version close to
r-rated but it's not r-rated I really
hope that's what Marvel will do with
this cuz I can see this going really
wrong if they're not gonna be doing any
of that side of things the sons of
midnight Elsa bloodstone mystic monster
verse all these things that you're
saying like well there needs to be a
little scary you know I'm gonna have a
hell of any kind or a Mephisto or
something like that it seems like yeah
you need to establish that ed and if
you're gonna go McCobb with that I think
you're absolutely right you need
that dark gritty formidable imposing
edge and I don't know if I should expect
it or not that's kind of the worry I
have is is it gonna be this sort of fun
poppy with horror wallpaper which you
know could work but I feel like leaves
you in a position to go wrong a lot
easier and I I think that either way
they should be going for this to at
least develop the Sons of midnight in
some way as I think getting more kind of
groups spin-off movies to build up to
other than just Avengers like we've got
in four great Avengers movies you've got
it like the Avengers 2.0 with civil war
I think building up to other groups
there were leaks coming out that they
could be building up to an a force movie
which sounds great and then building up
to sons of midnight that we have
multiple different spin-off groups you
can be building up to I think would be
more exciting and especially post
endgame era that's a lot to look forward
to also you know like with the whole
Sony's boom could spook speak you it
only gets nicer having that established
universe over and Sony where they have
Morbius it would make sense that if
you're gonna use Morbius in an official
MCU movie putting him in Sons of
midnight would be the best utilization
aliy think that way it lends itself to
less confusion - yeah when these like
weird separate universes that are also
tied but they're not really I it's kind
of weird
well yeah and you're gonna have this
spanning across not only that divide but
also between the shows the movies and
stuff like that and I mean there are
aspects of this that we don't even know
like who's gonna play Moon Knight yet
Keanu Reeves Keanu Reeves is just gonna
play every one Ghost Rider
yeah Ghost Rider sure let's Tony also
bloodstone they're actually rumors that
Daniel Radcliffe might be being
eyeballed for munites like the only name
that's been thrown out there the
Avengers I think will still persist but
especially moving forward and if you
think that Marvel plans phases but also
decades I feel like yeah having some
phases that maybe culminate in other
teams and then maybe do the decade where
they all come together or something like
that Canali cool but yeah I do think
that now we've really established the
MCU these kinds of prospects are very
exciting they're what I want I feel like
there's hope because of the Sony and of
all
in some ways what worries me is just
Disney's bottom line of like we're not
gonna cross the line into truly in a
proprietary yeah like I said doesn't
mean berated are yeah it just needs to
push the boundary it just needs to be
intense and scary yeah you know which
you can easily do in the pg-13 around we
have no idea what exactly went wrong
with Scott Derrickson
and Doctor Strange multiverse of madness
getting Sam Raimi on board excites me
because of the horror that he's done he
usually tries to infuse some of that
horror touch and whatever he does so
that excites me it's easy to read into
the creative differences of them because
he was very adamant at comic-con about
like this is gonna be a full-on horror
movie yeah and then the firing or the
splitting apart due to creative
differences this has a lot of rumor mill
going around you know like though they
don't really want to do that they wanted
to use multiverse of madness to be more
of a train into all these other
different worlds blah blah blah which is
something I imagine II wasn't into you
bottom line I know that's an old story
but the ripple effect of stories that
came out from that story have affected
my mind mo yeah and when I hear stuff
like this I'm like this is so awesome
yeah in context I love the idea the idea
I'm getting like Elsa bloodstone sounds
great universe building up to like
getting a crossover between blade dr.
strange Morbius and whomever else moon I
did that's all those have to wait and
see we have to go through a whole phase
for first yeah why don't we just skip to
phase 5 no Black Widow alright guys well
if you haven't done so already subscribe
to the cosmic Wonder Channel see if you
can win that Funko pop subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell tell us in the comments what do you
think about all this news last but not
least alfred benjamin threats the third
and mikhail linden mikhail are handsome
man from sweden and alfred are handsome
african-american gentleman from
Inglewood California
I wrote a fanfiction what if these two
met Mikael has been really looking
forward to bond and Alfred worse and
security oh I'll play Alfred I'll play
Mikhail do your best Swedish accent
to my best interior movie theater
evening late 2020 movie theaters have
recently reopened and a line has formed
for cautionary security checks to go
watch the latest Bond film no time to
die
Alfre benjamin threats a third handsome
buff scans attendees individually to
make sure they have the required
masculine gloves to watch the film
Mikhail Linden Swedish next in line
alright next alright alright without a
proper mast you can't enter the theater
no no whoa whoa whoa what's your deal
man it's just a movie
dog it's not just a movie this is the
latest Bond movie do you have any idea
how long I've been waiting for this I
moved from Sweden to the US just so I
could watch it earlier after all of its
noise chill man with that Dracula
Swedish accent you got going on it's not
like it's the latest Dwayne Johnson
movie who cares about the next door in
the Johnson movie well I care a dead man
all his movies got delayed why are we
even talking about Dwayne Johnson cuz
growing up in Inglewood California tommy
wise oh I wanted to be an actor Dwayne
Johnson was the man I looked up to most
okay
I didn't ask me a backstory but all
right please I can take my mask up and
watch oh all right then you got tape on
you no but can I borrow something
sorry man the worst treated people of
these events is security they won't let
me borrow any tape more unnecessary
backstory if you're sick of hearing my
backstory want to tell me some of yours
then I just want to watch the new Jenna
I get out of theater all right let me
think I love different kinds of sports
yeah kind of sports security is that the
sport you mocking me sweetie you just
call me sweetie
no sweetie cuz you you you said you're
from Sweden oh that's weird like hockey
soccer and motor sports my favorite NHL
team is the Colorado Avalanche what's
your name Linden
Makayla Linden yours third alfred
benjamin threats the third you do have a
threatening personality Oh more of that
sweetie pie
oops my ass attitude huh well you gotta
have a threatening personality when you
grow up in
Inglewood having 11 other siblings you
being the 12 sibling going into security
being treated poorly by your employers I
don't know why you're telling me so much
about your backs I want to open up my
own security company one day so other
people won't have to experience the
degradation I've had to endure the crowd
looks awkwardly upon McHale and Alfred
okay but don't touch me man Corona sorry
sorry look let's say I let you in to go
watch no time to die in the movie
theater with a packed audience of 20
people just give me one good reason why
I should let your Swedish Bond sci-fi
loving ass in here no I like cipher Greg
ruining the script but had to cut out
the part where you talked about it
because we had to say sometime wait wait
a minute Greg as in the real rejects
Greg album yeah
[ __ ] you subscribe yeah thanks
get out of here me too come on in man
Alfred let Mikael into the movie theater
without a mask where he passed a long
Cove in nineteen to everyone at his
screening
Mikael also didn't enjoy the movie what
are you gonna do
you